came to california uh with a truck
driver i was recently at a grocery store
in washington state and i happened to
ask him where he was going when i came
out of the store
and he said to california well i've
never been to california and i had the
guts to ask him can i go with him
because i had nothing going on for
myself
so um he said
sure and i said okay so i run around and
i jump in the truck
and i'm so excited i get to go with this
guy to california
i'm not thinking about my own self
so i go oh my god what am i doing i
can't do this he goes why i go are you
cool he goes what do you mean cool i go
come on cool are you cool and he goes oh
yeah yeah yeah i'm cool i go
i can't go with the kids i find out that
the truck driver is clean he just got
his [ __ ] together all that stuff
so
i asked her i told him i was strung out
in heroin and i have to have stuff to go
down you got to keep me well
and he says
i when i found out that it was clean i
was like oh no i can't do this i can't
do i can't do this to you no no i don't
want to do this because knowing that he
was a strong heroin addict for a long
time too i didn't want to be the cause
of that again
so anyway he grabbed my arm he goes no i
want you to go and i went are you for
real
and he said yeah i promise it won't
bother me it won't bother me oh my god
okay once a heroin addict most likely
always a heroin addict if it comes
around you okay
well he knew i had dope on me and i
tried my best to go in the in the cat in
the tr in the back to do my stuff but
once he saw it he asked me for a little
bit and i was like oh my god how can i
tell this guy no you know
so it gradually ended up him doing some
me doing some we end up getting strung
out we go all across the world
um
hauling
wood christmas trees you know uh uh
albertson's stuff you know food
all that stuff so anyway we did that for
about two years
and um
also we got to albertsons to low unload
and um i was sat in the truck because i
had abscess this huge on my arm
so i sat in the truck while he went to
go talk to the the big guys
um
and
somebody comes running out to the truck
to me miss miss come right now your
boyfriend's been hurt your husband's
been hurt
and i jump all the way from the
passenger street all the way to the
ground off the truck and i'm like oh my
god i just know this app set i just know
this abscess is going to pop on me but i
had to be professional so i just went in
there come find out he was walking to go
get a a soda
and a guy in a forklift a kid with
headphones on little earplugs headphones
was jamming out to music
he was correctly in the yellow lines
like he was supposed to be the kid did
not see him swung around
knocked him down and ran over his
broke this leg here and broke this leg
here
crushed his toes it was awful on a on a
um forklift
and it was just awful i couldn't believe
it um
ambulance came rushing to the hospital i
had to take care of the truck even
though i didn't have a license or cdl or
nothing but i knew how to drive one
so
i
he was already in surgery by the time i
i um got there because i followed the
ambulance and stuff how to get there and
i just hung out in the truck and um i
was there when he woke up and that was
the end of that career
so then we became homeless of course
he got a settlement from um he got a
settlement
from albertsons for 90 000 they want to
give them 60 000. i said no go up your
whole career is ruined you know because
of this
so he went up asked for 90 000. they
gave him 90 000 and it was
hotels motels good food and drugs
he bought a harley
and
we just did the best we could and
he slowly dwindled away
went to the doctors because he got had
an infection in his lungs
come find out he had a dime size in his
lung of cancer
and
two weeks three weeks later we went to
the doctor again a doctor says the
cancer has gone to your from your lungs
to your brain so he only had a limited
time to go
and so
i didn't know what to do for him i don't
know what i could do for him just be a
good friend to him and be there
so
[Music]
i sent him i called him on the phone one
day
when i knew that was getting worse and
worse
um
i just
told him how i felt that i can't look i
love you so much i cannot sit there and
watch you doing the way and die i just
can't do it i love you with all my heart
i will cherish the eight years we were
together always in my heart but i just
can't do it i cannot watch you
pass i just can't
so
that was the end of us
from there i just
started working the streets again doing
my thing
and then i'd say
four months later
i was standing on 7th in town here
minding my own business working
and it's about 12 30
and this beautiful long-haired blonde
guy
pulls over in a 4x4 truck it says hey
what are you doing and i said not much
you working yeah
okay hey come on get in so i get in we
do our business and he was so infatuated
with me he says would you i'd like to
take you out to hemet for the weekend
and i said oh that sounds great and then
once again the same thing are you cool
because
i can't go out there i'll be deathly ill
you know if i don't truly be honest and
tell him what's going on and he did not
do dope then he was clean hard worker
concrete finisher run a crew the whole
nine yards and i'm thinking of my brain
i scored you know and uh i was with him
for 14 years
14 years
amazing
and
he's still my very good friend right now
he lives on fifth and wall in an sro i
go come see him once a week make sure
that he's okay because he's getting up
there 64.
go shopping for him all that get away
from my house because my kids are at my
house right now
living with me
so
yeah
it's amazing your drug now is what um my
drug now is fentanyl i've been on it for
about two and a half years
my prior drug was heroin and i did that
for almost 40 years how do they compare
um i wouldn't touch heroin again in my
life
don't even have no desire for it at all
not even to pick up a needle nothing i
rather smoke the the fentanyl so fennel
has his reputation as being this yes
horrible horrible death disease you know
and i mean death drug and uh
it's not you just have to know what
you're doing you don't take god
hits of fentanyl if you've never done it
before you don't take god hits of
fentanyl if you have a quantum pin in
you or or or or uh uh
god what's the word what's the other one
uh uh
got any kind of strong um painkiller you
know you don't do that you don't mix it
because that's how you die too
you know you take a little you gradually
work your
self up
one by one and for myself i'm i'm so
damn strong and stuff now which is
terrible
that um
i don't think i could find anything that
would get me high
how old are you now
i'm 60 years old now
opiates since you were i've been doing
opiates since 33.
so when you were 18 you were met the
trucker
yes you weren't using
uh you were a little bit a little bit
yeah you said you were yeah
yeah that's how it started and then my
sister with cocaine
um i saw her do it and when i was like
16 and i wanted to try some of that and
then i you know i knew what the needle
was on cocaine and all i did was run you
know i just ran when i when it got me
high how did you get how did you get
into this this crazy lifestyle drugs and
i i think it was just me wanting to do
whatever the hell i wanted to do was
your childhood life
my childhood was very good my
mother and father were married and
married for 40 years
my dad was a retired major in the army
and
my mother was a homemaker she had maybe
one or two jobs but mainly staying at
home
um
after that my dad got a job at the post
office he was a mailman for 20 years um
i was the last of six children
i've watched a lot of alkyl
alcoho
alkaliz alcoholism going on when i was
young of course my mom and dad drank
they're alcoholics
violence going on all that kind of thing
so that's probably the reason why i
don't drink too you know because that
memory came
at 12 years old that memory comes right
back to me even now you know because i
remember it picture it and there's just
awful
knives and
fighting and violence no
not for me but my parents are both
deceased now they've been deceased for
quite a long time now do you
point the finger at
the
alcoholism in your family or
the violence and the abuse that you
both both i'd say both yeah makes sense
both and then i don't blame anybody for
my drug use because that's my choice
i don't blame anybody um
maybe my sister told me no you know but
she didn't she'd let me
she let me amuse it anyway to see what
it was like you know
do you regret taking this this path in
your life oh yeah yeah i mean i've had
i've had like really nice boyfriends all
down the line but drugs were involved in
it you know i can't be with you
if
you know
you're a beautiful woman i'm sure you're
gonna have you you've had lots of guys
that want to take care of you yeah well
a couple and when i do meet somebody i'm
i'm i'm solid you know i don't go cheat
i don't don't do tricks i don't do
nothing like that of course i'm 69 i
don't even hardly do that no more anyway
unless emergency shows up but i have to
do it you know
but other than that no i'm i i finally
did the footwork for an sro
um it took me five years to get the
place i was homeless for ten how long
have you homeless ten years ten years
yeah
um me and randy were homeless together
and
um
we were we parked our tent right in
front on beverly street the homeless
healthcare so they could see us every
freaking day see their windows
you know doing water to wash our hair
just sweeping the area folding my
clothes
recycling getting up and recycling every
morning
it's been it's been hell and i'm just
glad i'm grateful that i'm not homeless
anymore
so kids
yes i have three children
um my husband got the first one so i
haven't seen him since he's been six
this is part of my drug use
behavior you know
and um something i still need to take
care of and make a phone call and talk
to him and
things happen in life man you know
things just happen
um so anyway and then i have um
my second marriage
um
matthew and christopher chris matthew
christopher yes
i have two also all boys they're all
adults right now
so
yeah
it's been it's been a hell of a run for
me actually and now i'm on the run on
the fentanyl and
i i don't know i've been thinking about
how tired i am doing the drug you know
and my age and everything else so
it's probably time for me to quit
when you think
you know so
have you ever had jobs
jobs have you ever had a job yes i used
to at 18 i was working for the sizzler
before we took off and all that uh
i've had boyfriends prior to that too
like a drummer in a band and
three years with them and
um yeah it's it's
you know when i was 18 it wasn't so bad
because i just had one boyfriend and
then when i came to l.a is when i when i
started doing that
all the the real negative stuff you know
going the wrong way but that comes with
drugs and heroin except that's just goes
together like
you know do you blame l.a for any of it
um no no i don't it's just something i
found that was easy and fast and that's
what i like you know i'm giving you
something and i'm getting something from
you you know that's all it is go home to
your wife afterwards you know
so
i don't know
some people think god that's so cold you
know it is so cold but not when you're
on the streets like that trying to
survive you know every the the dates
understand
because they're already married you know
or got in a fight with their their gal
or whatever just went to the store and
they haven't seen me you know
so
yeah it's
if you had your life to live all over
again what would you have done
differently oh god i'd go to college go
to college learn a trait
and um
go trucking probably i really like
trucking a lot i know that i drive a
semi
you know and i know a lot of the rules i
know the only thing i don't have i don't
know about that is i'm trying to back up
back up it's a little hard for me
and when i was with my boyfriend he had
a tough kingpin you know and oh god i'd
almost get it but i just couldn't get it
all away
[Laughter]
what are you afraid of no i'm afraid of
now
being at home dying in front of my kid
just
gone
you know just like that
um
yeah
it's a little scary i'm getting up there
so
but i don't feel like i'm 60. i really
don't i still feel very youthful
my mind's very youthful still
um i've done a lot now it's like
fentanyl cigarettes oh my god i'm
coughing up you know in the morning
getting all that crap out you know
but i mean i still i mean like in the
some some days i walk really fast you
know get my heart rate going where it's
not just sitting around laying around
all the time at a regular heartbeat you
know trying to get it going again take
some vitamins
try to try to do a little bit better for
my life you know
what would you say renee is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
i was a person to be responsible
to have your own place
treat people with respect
you and ask don't steal
no
that's right and um always think before
you do something
because there's nothing i can do about
my life now is besides tell it because i
can't i can't turn around i mean i can
still turn around
you know and be better you can always be
a better person
but
to change the past you cannot so the
important message for me is
don't lag in your past stay in the
future
you know don't blame others for your
your your mistakes you know because
you're the one that made the choice to
do it
you know
so all right renee thank you so much for
sharing your story yes yes that's just
one of many
[Laughter]
[Music]
one of many
you